so this morning we dealt with this but
my take we can move up to the modern
period with see Jim ping it's really
there's elite nationalism and mass
nationalism in China we heard of the the
patriotic national education program
that indoctrinates everybody into a
Chinese view the whole South China Sea
is theirs but elite nationalism fits
into the sea Jinping's dream of the
great revitalization now or nationally
Juvia rejuvenation to overcome that
century of national humiliation the mass
nationalism has taken an anti-japanese
turn over the sink aku's and i now think
that china has moved into a pay a period
of chauvinism the entire discussion of
China's historic rights doesn't have the
peoples of Southeast Asia who lived
there even mentioned it's just Chinese
and it's like 2,000 years ago there's no
one else living in the region and we
know from anthropological work that's
not true and it's leading to aggressive
patriotism
we're not once Chinese captain to my
knowledge has ever been punished for
crashing into a Vietnamese both
murdering a Vietnamese skipper beating
up the crew they can all operate with
impunity protecting this nine-dash line
and then we have the hacktivists and the
taking out of yet amis web sites into
facing them and language that is
scatological so now I'm focusing on
China and we could find nationalism we
heard in Vietnam in Reverse but so I
just want to mention that so you have a
Chinese position the Chinese activities
in the South China Sea date back over
2,000 years ago who else was there huh
China was the first country to discover
named explorer to exploit the resources
of the Chou China Sea Islands and the
first continuously exercised sovereign
powers over them China is like the water
is like the 19th century or earlier
white man that came to Australia and
look at this big island and said it's
tearin Ellis we occupy it and the
Aborigines don't have any say well now
our high courts have ruled the
indigenous people do in Australia and if
I were in Australia sneaking out I would
not have begun my presentation without
acknowledging the original inheritors of
that land and so in this 21st century to
totally ignore
the peoples of Southeast Asia who maybe
not had a high Han Dynasty but they
certainly were there and traversing it
needs to be taken into account so we
have domestic actors fueling in and
backing it's all me to the fishing
industry provincial level we get
subsidies we can go on the oil industry
and it's very various companies and it's
always over capacity oversupply but
China can afford to pick up the tab
provincial government so on the littoral
areas maritime law enforcement agency
once the five dragons now the Coast
Guard and others have taken it and of
course the People's Liberation Army Navy
so we go to fisheries here there are
over a hundred thousand vessels in the
north of the that operate in the South
China Sea
one hundred and some-odd major fishing
trawlers instead these ships are courage
to have steel hulls and depending on the
sizes of their engines are given more
subsidies and encouraged because China
has over fished and polluted its zones
to move further and further south it's a
massive problem in the South China Sea
is that we're facing really a potential
crisis in the next decades if not now
over that it's exaggerated by the sheer
rapacious nature blowing up reefs to get
giant clams to get aphrodisiacs for the
men massive sea protesting ships and so
the artificial islands that I'm building
up will serve as four operating bases
for these interests and with that the
military from China's point you must
then protect them if we could turn to
hydrocarbon resorbed no one has ever
done a good survey but the US Energy
Information Agency cooked up with a
hundred doing china's estimates are
three to 28 times larger than America so
they must they believe that there's all
this oil but interesting special to say
its peak oil you're thirsty man you give
them a can of coke or a bottle of water
he drinks it that's gone so very quickly
that China is even if the economy slows
down and had all the oil that could get
it within decades that would be gone so
what's the earth you still have to
import it from elsewhere all of the
hydrocarbon reserves the 67% are really
gas and it's in the southern reaches of
the South China Sea
so the fisheries are pushing south and
that's where the oil and gas is
and then for the exploration you have
these massive this is one of two more on
stream that we heard referred to earlier
the high-end shoe yo or the HD 91 but
they were called China's national mobile
territory who goes exploring for oil
with 80 to 100 ships let's surround them
and who can have the cosa who could have
fishermen who are supposed to be earning
a living out there crashing into
Vietnamese but they do it because
they're subsidized they're an arm and
there are a militia of the Chinese state
so that's just moving to geo strategic
imperatives which I think are more
important from a Chinese protect
perspective
America has a Cold War mentality and to
me they've got a continental mentality
tough luck if you're a continent you've
got neighbors and you got Islands off it
that's geography you are surrounded but
it didn't happen with the Cold War it
happened by birth of geography so they
say US rebalancing is containment and
Daniel kept mentioning a2/ad and for the
uninitiated that's the Pentagon
translation of Chinese counter
interventions strategy anti access area
denial foods just just to mention that
but Chinese call it counter intervention
as Chinese economy economy has grown
they have a mercantilist thing about
trying to build all the shiny ships to
take the oil to do all the trade they
have to protect their sea lines of
communication which stretch across and
power projection to go with it and I'll
be focusing on Hainan and woody islands
and the artificial islands so from the
rebalancing as containment is that
network of American bases left over from
the Second World War Japan and Korea and
now on Guam returned to the Philippines
on rotational basis Wow
500 Marines 2,000 Marines maximum and in
Darwin no one ever knows that the US
China and the u.s. conduct military
exercises
they're very small-scale the survival
exercises but China is part of it in
that and then you have so you and then
the basing of the Poseidon's in
Singapore and Malaysia etc that the
China Seas this is a containment of
itself and then we heard Daniel point
out that for China to project power that
a 95 96
when Taiwan was almost using the I
independence word China law of missiles
in the in the Straits to try to
intimidate China America sent to carrier
task groups in a sense China Rizal never
again let's push the American military
out the major contingency for China is
Taiwan but the larger strategic picture
comes into it as well and we have to
take that both so it's it's to push
America out beyond that first island
chain further into the western Pacific
by combining land-based aircraft
missiles as well as naval ships and
everything else that I pictured here so
that is to secure the southern flank is
vulnerable the u.s. is in Guam it can
come around you can sail up through
there and Hainan Island is a major base
so they need a screening zone to protect
that deployment and I mentioned see
lines of communication you hear that you
hear the Chinese Malacca dilemma the
Malacca dilemma is a like a choke point
that at times of conflict the Americans
could close it off and China
you know would be isolated that's partly
true except it's I have a Australian
Admiral tell me it's not a choke point
because they're alternate waves a choke
point is one that you turn it off and
you can't travel us straits of hormuz so
you don't have to bring it there and
that southern Chinese provinces hype
them a lack of dilemma so they can get
funds to build land routes through a
fear on larger initiatives itself but
nonetheless China does have legitimate
interest in protecting it and no one
else protects your on sea lanes except
yourself okay Chinese we'll hear more
from you in a moment about the maritime
law enforcement agencies and civil but
increasingly more and more combat
oriented practical exercises
particularly this year landing on
Islands they've done it before and from
an Australian perspective the perfectly
normal and under acceptable under
international law but sailing down
appearing off the coast of northern
Australia passing through the Straits of
Sunda in the Lombok you know we're a
long bail that's why we're commissioning
12 French submarines of the future that
we feel our interest I've got got to be
the problem is that China it's
developing a large military and it's not
exactly good on transparency or telling
us what it's doing and its behavior so
from about 2007 2008 it built a major
naval base on Hainan Island with James
Bond types that's the press telling us
of underground tunnels where they have
conventional and the Jin class I thought
it was five who ssp ends they are
ballistic missile nuclear carrying
submarines for those not used to the
terminology SSB ends and their base
there and the most modest modernisation
of the three fleets that China has is
taking place in the southern one and
Hainan Island must now be protected from
all its approaches because it's a major
base so that adds on to it we have
plenty of discussion on woody island
where it's been militarized for years
I'm highly critical of the American
freedom of navigation patrols there was
testing law but it was a distraction
from the in my point of view from the
spaten he's much more important and we
saw that when the second fear of
navigation patrol was launched China put
in a very high high level anti-aircraft
missile system the radar to go with it
and up to ten jet another aircraft
itself they administer it from times
past by raising the level of sanchow to
a prefecture and give it give it this is
this is their administration over the
macker field bank and everything just to
caring it's it's Chinese how you do that
this chart here it's difficult it comes
from the Office of Naval Intelligence
shows the number of Coast Guard vessels
China 205 is greater than all the other
countries in the region in number the
difference in sizes are those above 1000
tons and below 1000 tonnes and that's
misleading because of China you start at
3,000 tons these days that move up to
5,000 tons and since I'm in America I
can say it it's difficult to use the
words in Australia it's like an American
high school football team playing
against the pros you eventually are
going to be pushed down the field by the
sheer mass and size of those numbers as
we saw over the HD 981 and these are the
cutting edge but their arms ships and
they have Elektra
electromagnetic warfare capabilities
that have isolated Indonesian ships that
have apprehended fishermen and forced
them to give up and so and because
they're white hauled in is Daniel was
pointing out creates an asymmetric
challenge and if poor Philippines sent a
former Coast Guard ship but commissioned
in its Navy to arrest fishermen China
made a meal the biggest ship and the
Philippines Navy well Wow anyway so when
we go down to the the seven islands all
right yeah seven artificial islands in
the South China Sea
I am adamant and I started using the
words that I've corrected myself in
writing noting that China's doing is
land reclamation there is no island
above water at high tide that had soil
eroded by wind or sea their loads height
elevations or rocks and the fact that
you build an artificial island doesn't
change their original status and the
triangle I've done here and I've years
ago when General Schafer was telling
everybody about larger triangles no one
wanted to listen each one of them has a
3,000 meter airstrip as one American
outlaw said 747 would take off and it'd
be an extra nine hundred and fifteen
meters left b-52 could do it just fine
but it'd be too short for a space
shuttle and you can then said almost any
plane in the Chinese military inventory
could be based there for periods of time
but they would need fuel storage and
revetments so but the fact that they say
it's for search and rescue other
countries have airfields and when you do
search and rescue under ICAO the
International Convention you're supposed
to cooperate with regional states this
is China's big on in infrastructure
projects they could have built up the
one from Malaysia and the Philippines
which is ramshackle and Viet Nam's less
than six hundred meter thing and they
could do search and rescue that way
China claims it's only catching up and
this was released in the u.s.
asia-pacific strategy report and it's a
timeline showing what they've done I did
a report that will come out at the
shangri-la dialogue and they removed a
lot because they said Mia's not military
what Vietnam and other countries would
do not China and I said that was
precisely the point because China says
we're catching up and only doing what
other people do yeah you end up creating
a massive area out of nothing that
dwarfs the area of countries and where
they Vietnam used to bring barges and
dump soil one recently they've been
caught out with some dredging a
particular area but the militarization
and putting that infrastructure in is of
an order of magnitude that's different
so here yeah it shows what everybody's
doing I end on these kind of snapshots
this is a fiery cross reef showing
what's now a completed runway this is
the Forward Operating headquarters
this is the place that communicates to
planes flying over it doesn't Jam the
Poseidon but it jams Philippine military
aircraft as they fly over it's a virtual
air defense zone China says get out of
our military alert area yo you're
threatening Chinese ships of they have
no capacity yet to enforce it but what's
is this military alert zone an
artificial island does not have any
airspace it's an artificial island 500
meters around it safety zone but none of
the other entitlements itself sube
this is the triangle we're talking about
now fiery cross is opposite Vietnam and
if you put anti-submarine warfare planes
in there the stealth factor of Vietnam's
enhanced kilos would be undermined and
into all this I forgot to make an
earlier point on the island chain is
that the US has a system called a
socialist system a sound underwater
system so that first island chain
through to Taiwan could detect the
transit of submarines so if China needs
a reliable deterrent nuclear force so
America if attacked China first they
could take out Los Angeles of
retaliation if their submarines are
known then their ability to have a
secure second strike deterrent is
undermined so in the South China Sea
there's talk there are very deep water
channels that the submarines of all
navies traverse but with these places
here China could
at own social sin and begin to mark the
transit of the US it's the great game at
the nuclear level and that's why I say
geopolitics is now prime China stronger
the u.s. rebalances has challenged it
and this is sube where another 3,000 a
meter strip has been put in a mischief
reef again this is the comparison of air
strips the problem is there's only one
for China and there should be three so
there's you know that that is the size
and in the Philippines one of my former
students this is their Western Command
commander took journalists there and the
plane almost went off the dirt runway
because it's so bad so you know women
try it's only catching up whatever now
they can let me just end with two points
two slides what's the purpose
China says it's building these islands
to improve the living conditions of
Chinese that are there providing
neurological data
you remember in nineteen eighty eight
eighty seven that was the pretext for
we're seizing fiery cross reef from the
Vietnamese and killing sixty odd
Bethenny's engineers scientific research
search and rescue shelter for fishing
boats a base for oil exploration support
for the Coast Guard and of course as I
say when all these assets are there
you've got to defend them and then China
says it's based on the level of threat
so whatever the US does in the
Philippines is a wonderful pretext
America does this we must step up our
military defense capacity in my I'm at
the Australian Defence Force Academy and
I don't speak for the Defense Department
but at the University of New South Wales
employs us so we have freedom in
Australia academic freedom dealing with
our military but the people I talk to an
American Admirals in public say these
are will be forward operating bases
opposed really and they have not yet put
in fuel storage which would tell us
exactly you know what capacities they
would have but they have constructed
piers for naval combatants they've
landed military aircraft but not kept
them they're chock senior Chinese
command have recently visited long-range
radar so China would be able to have
pick up and you know quite well what's
going on there and respawn and the
response to be to get out of our area or
to
shoulder you away from that advanced and
the aircraft missile systems in an air
defense identification zone so I was
prompted to add a new slide to this as a
result I wanted to a Sarika this morning
we used the word to demilitarize there
is that massive debate between the US
and China on militarization who's doing
it and it calls for a definition what
I've tried to do is say it is a spectrum
of activities and the ordinary
dictionary sense militarization means to
give a military character to a place I'm
at the University of South Wales on the
defence Academy all my students are
cadets and Midshipmen it's militarized
they're wearing uniforms and occasional
security guards carry sidearms when the
security threats go up though okay so
you do that too all the way over
militarization is putting in place the
fortifications were listed in the Rico's
case the fortifications and naval
vessels I think were the only two items
making preparations for war putting in
that revetted hangars fuel storage and
the kind of offensive amphibious forces
etc so one of the problems of defining
militarization is that a 3,000 meter
long airship can support search and
rescue it can have air buses of tourists
flying down from China I could do
medical evacuation you could host a
conference of Yale scholars and fly them
out there you know friendly child
spending into China
so this dual use and they could rapidly
change but when you move over to the red
line it's offensive capability and
that's militarization and it would be
for the the leaders in the region to
define what that is so I'm 14 seconds
shy of the 20 minutes I thank you